at least six people have died after
their boat capsized while trying to
reach the UK from France 49 others were
rescued local officials say dozens of
boats carrying migrants were trying to
cross the channel from France French
prosecutors are investigating
they were in trouble there was the
problem of seasickness and then also the
boats are quite simply overloaded they
overload the boats and so they can no
longer move forward the last boat where
we intervened was too full
[Music]
following developments from Dover on
England's south eastern coast and Paul
how have the rescue if it's been carried
out from the English side of the channel
so far
well Tom a Lifeboat left the port of
Dover here at about 4 a.m local time
that's after the signal had gone up that
um vessels were in trouble off uh sangat
near Dunkirk on the on the French Coast
um when they arrived there were
apparently according to one of the
mayors of one of the towns on the coast
dozens of Migrant vessels trying to all
make the crossing at the same time one
of those capsized and six people were
found in a very serious condition one of
those was airlifted to hospital in
Calais was pronounced dead shortly
afterwards and it was then later on
confirmed that the other five had died
as well around 50 people rescued as you
say now this all comes after after
755 people
um tried to cross the channel on on
Thursday apparently taking taking
advantage of the of the karma whether
the weather hasn't been quite quite as
calm today we've not heard anything
about the search and rescue operation
being officially over but a short time
ago we did see a Lifeboat coming back
into the port of Dover
um apparently not with any any migrants
aboard though and what is the UK
government's response been to this
well the the Home Secretary swella
bravaman is sharing a meeting of the the
so-called uh small boats operational
command gold she said her her thoughts
and prayers go out to the people
affected uh by this tragedy and their
and their families
um the home secretary's already been
dealing with the Fallout of of 17
migrants
um who were rescued by the the UK
Authorities on Thursday also the Fallout
of the of the government's policies of
of housing migrants on a barge some 200
miles along the coast in Portland
um in a barge that was found to have
Legionella bacteria in the in the water
system
um this week with those those Asylum
Seekers being taken off the barge
yesterday this this comes in a week when
the government's trying to showing
trying to show that it's cracking down
on small boat arrivals in the UK
this incident today shows just how
dangerous The Crossing is these 20 miles
between the French coast and the UK but
campaigners already saying that the
government shouldn't be cracking down on
the small boat arrivals what they should
be doing is making more safe routes for
migrants to arrive in the UK and claim
Asylum okay thank you so much that is
Paul Reese for us in Dover